hello I'm Morten and I'm here to talk to
you today about apparently introducing
the testing Dimond who here is expecting
a testing talk with the classic kind of
pyramid thing on it and that kind of
thing
anyone yeah I promise you no pictures
it's all good ice cream cone maybe a
little bit fluff no okay so I work
currently as a principal devote for the
ministry of justice more specifically in
the office of the Public Guardian what
we do is look after lasting powers of
attorney so altruistically good hooray
not many people get to say that yeah all
right okay so by way of introduction I
know the testing is a super highly
opinionated space I'm not really here to
peddle my particular opinion I'm more
going to address some of the broader
concerns and get you to think more
hopefully about trade-offs when you come
to choosing the type of tests that
you're going to pick and hopefully be a
little bit less hung up on what each
individual word means because that's
that's a road to hell right there okay
so just quick quick gauge of interest
who here really enjoys like a TDD
approach to writing code cool rock on
who enjoys spike flow and writing stuff
in kind of a BDD style format yes sir
that's cool I'm not going to mention any
kind of implementation of how you do
this stuff so just whichever way you do
it they'll sub to you yeah we're going
to talk about kind of overall how you
pin the different types of tests
together to have a sustainable strategy
and the other thing that I would
hopefully get away well you go away with
from this talk is a sense that the most
important thing you can do other than
weaving some maintainable strategies is
part of that is building it into the
sense of community in your local teams
and businesses because ultimately the
only way to sustain testing effort is
making it a cultural thing I won't go
over it in a lot of detail but please
keep I might so the plan I always like
to start with the value of what I'm
doing so here we're going to talk about
what is the value that I'm actually
expecting to deliver with with automated
tests so will will kind of treat this as
a product type exercise maybe or at
least that kind of view so you would be
able to engage with any other
stakeholder in your team and talk about
kind of what is the value of what I'm
trying to achieve they will then move on
to talking about the language this isn't
to establish my opinion about what the
words mean it's more just to establish
in a very short space the Dedede
equivalent of some ubiquitous language
so that we're all thinking and talking
about the same things at least for the
duration of this talk if you go away and
had completely different uses for these
words that's fine use them how have you
wish but I need to establish a common
dialogue just for this talk and then
lastly we'll move on to strategy and how
you weave these things together to form
overall coherent and maintainable
strategies for testing and we'll just
look at one or two micro examples if you
have broader questions I really welcome
them particularly at the end but also
after the talk I'll be going down to
floor two and setting a table for awhile
and if you want to come and just talk
that's cool
I won't bite okay so we will start with
value excuse me
so testing is a product this is actually
one of my favorite exercises to run
through when I start up a community or
something like that community of
practice is why is the value that we're
trying to achieve to treat it almost
like a mini design sprint you think
about your personas and your actors and
you talk about why these stakeholders
expecting of others of our of our
contract with them but in this case
we're talking about testing so
fundamentally what do we want out of
their tests and most commonly I think
James short touches on this a little bit
in some of his blogs but we want to
establish confidence that the software
under test works the way that we expect
it to and we want to be able to document
the behavior of that application under
test so that we can clearly then like or
hopefully any member joining the team
can then very quickly get up to speed
with that product and we want to
introduce a really solid tight feedback
loop and those are really the tenants
that we're trying to achieve yeah and
when I say tight that isn't obviously
the only only thing that gives feedback
value there are other aspects to these
things but I'm going to focus on just a
few of the aspects and connotations of
these things I might explain some of the
broader terms but we're going to focus
on just a few bits because of time so
inverting the idea of thinking about
testing as a product is usually one of
the exercises what are the main risks to
our value what are the things that are
owed the the mission and one of the key
things for eroding the value of your
test suite if you're looking at
confidence is unreliable or flaky tests
there's nothing faster than okay
another quick poll has anybody here
worked in a place it's okay you don't
have to give it away but where you've
had their Suites which is in the
pipeline somewhere and you run it maybe
three times just just just to get the
test passing yeah
what's your confidence level that the
code actually works after that process
the next to zero yeah that would be B
correct yeah so confidence if if you're
not achieving that that's a problem
documentation this will get interesting
on the next slide but one of the key
things for documentation is say when you
look at documentation for anything else
in the public domain is there stuff
missing from the documentation can you
find out how to do the things that you
expect to do so a nice way of thinking
about documentation is well testing
documentation is are there any gaps will
I know how this thing behaves will I be
able to find out and feedback other than
kind of go for measurable things here
which you'll see why in a moment but one
of the key things for feedback is its
speed if you have to wait an hour to
find out if your tests still pass that's
that's an hour of you maybe going and
making a cup of coffee the very I guess
as possible these days
does anybody grind their own beans and
that kind of thing no yeah excellent but
possibly not the most productive use of
your time anyway gratification here in
tight loops and being able to see the
results of your work quickly I think
we're all sold other things in feedback
can be like the quality of the feedback
that you get so whether there's adequate
tracing or something like that of what's
going on in your tests so that you can
understand how to fix a problem if it
arises I'll touch that again in a sec
and this comes back to transparency but
so we've established kind of the mission
that we want to achieve in terms of
value we've talked about some of the key
risks and to make this really
transparent to the other people that you
work with because transparency is power
even if it is a vulnerable thing to do
is to basically provide an interface or
a common set of numbers that somebody
else can also understand
and you can link it back to the value
that you say you're delivering so for
example with confidence you could
measure the regularity with which some
tests fail so if you have some tests
that fail on a regular basis and you're
keeping track of the error counts of
those things it's a pretty good
call-to-action to say these tests like
these tests fail a lot maybe we should
have a ticket or looking at
documentation coverage now I've put ish
just though again out of interest does
anybody have a coverage target that they
punch for okay I'm on the fence I am
Switzerland no this can be a tool for
good and a tool for bad it depends how
you wield it like every tool so coverage
how how many folks through my given code
base am i covering with tests coverage
in this case is more of a gauge of how
much documentation is there how much the
products can I show how it works
particularly if you've inherited an
existing pre-loved system yes I saw that
excellent work an existing pre-loved
system then it's not going to have
wonderful coverage most likely and then
you might want to take a risk-based
approach to introducing testing when I
say risk-based I mean what the areas
where we're most likely to have to
introduce change what areas have caused
us the most issues historically you
could look at bug reports you could talk
to your support team if you have that
kind of facility which areas have the
highest Chan which areas have the
highest complexity or those are good
indicators but in terms of measuring
value of the suite and how it's
delivering coverage gives you a rough
indication of how much documentation
there is it shouldn't ever ideally in my
experience be used as a hammer because
it might encourage
bad behavior so has anybody ever seen
any code where somebody's punching for
hire coverage so what they've done is
invert this problem and just write a
load of nonsense tautology code sorry a
trooper truism so a path that is always
correct and then write a load of tests
that covered the nonsense bit just to
make the bit above it pass pass the
coverage statistic I know that I've seen
that that's okay it's not okay don't do
that it can encourage gamification and
poor behavior it also can be the case
that for certain kinds of coverage it
can be difficult to achieve under
certain circumstances but setting a
hard-and-fast goal all these things are
local context sensitive so if you saw
some humans talk about tear it up and
start again I'd say this is one of the
things where you want some global
consistency maybe in the things that you
measure but you want some local
consistency about what your targets are
or your service level objectives I guess
but what your targets are for those
measures for some teams it'll make sense
the punch for more coverage or faster
faster execution runs or less tolerance
around task failure for other teams it's
important to be local context sensitive
to be forgiving and maybe punch for
better targets over time
next up feedback the key obvious thing
here is time I think the rough rule of
thumb that I've seen a lot of teams
adopt is if it takes longer than just
going and quickly grabbing a drink so
five minutes then it's probably taking
too long to run the whole suite whatever
that suite is the last aspect I wanted
to touch on was the idea of Delta so you
can apply each of these well
particularly the coverage and time
metrics to the whole time a test suite
takes to execute or the coverage of a
whole suite but that by Delta here I
mean the Delta introduced by a single
pull request that can be really powerful
and interesting because
if say somebody raises pull request and
all of a sudden your tests take three
four times longer to run that's that's a
big call to action maybe that pull
request shouldn't get through or
likewise if your car coverage takes like
a absolute nosedive that's that's a
really interesting thing maybe talk
about it and it can also encourage good
boy scouting like we maintain at least
this level of thing / / Delta so we've
covered value of cupboard value next up
I'm going to establish some common
language
this is contentious I know okay so I'm
only going to introduce a few testing
terms and this will just be to cover the
two examples that I'm going to cover
this isn't going to be the whole gamut
of potential types of tests that you can
write i we wouldn't we'd still be here
when the party in pub comes it is
waiting happily go to pub conference
that's great so we're not going to do
that so for UI
end-to-end testing what I'm really
talking about here is your selenium
style or Cypress thing that's maybe
crawling a page looking at CSS selectors
clicking buttons the underlying stuff
I'm really talking about having a real
kind of stack there where possible and
you might have you might have variations
there the time and speed and reliability
compromises that's all cool but in this
particular example it's using as many
real moving parts as possible the value
per test is an interesting thing to talk
about so the value of a UI test if you
think back to the things that we're
trying to achieve earlier the value the
confidence delivered by a working UI
test is incredibly high because it
exercises a lot of your stack a lot of
logic a lot of things but the trade-off
here is that in terms of feedback
they're known to be slow like it's a
it's a problem
incredibly difficult to get around so if
we're looking at our metrics there's a
there's a trade-off there and likewise
there famously brittle painlessly
brittle for a variety of reasons you can
be very careful about how you write this
kind of thing and achieve stable tests
to a degree but the ongoing kind of
maintenance effort there is high is very
high so that gives you kind of a flavor
of what what the trade-offs are for a UI
test and how we might want to think
about it when we're developing an
overall strategy and I've include a
little note here about where because I
got some feedback fortunately before I
made for myself in front of everybody
but I want to be clear about where I ran
these tests in my cycle so for me I try
and say that any automated tests where
at all possible should be runnable
locally so you can get feedback again
going back to the values we get the
feedback instantly or as close to
instantly as we can and the further
rights it gets pushed the worse the
value is delivered by that suite if we
have to wait all the way for it to be
like deployed on some environment X Y
Zed and something to be run over it
there that's that's that's potentially
quite a long time I know that can
require quite a bit of engineering
effort but I think it's honestly the
trade-offs for that are extremely worth
it
next down the snack yeah okay
so I'm assuming here a spa of some
description maybe it's a microphone tent
maybe it's cot and a view
Jess or something but a component test
was probably a thing that rose with the
rise of angular but it is the idea of
testing a single UI component and in its
modern form probably came up for the spa
generation and it's quite nice it put
the isolation here because you talked
about isolation a lot with tests here
being your isolating the concerns of the
thing under test to just be that thing
and the isolation here is around the
idea of a component
I know this isn't probably news to a lot
of you but we're going to just cover the
terms so that everybody's on the same
page and the beauty of these tests is
that they are run in isolation but they
Pro can provide a fair bit more value
than a the definition of a unit test
we'll see in a minute because they cover
the whole interaction and contract that
that component has with the other
elements of the UI and that provides a
fair amount of value not as much
obviously as a full-on UI test but the
benefit here the trade-off here is that
the feedback cycle much much shorter and
the determinism how irregular you can
put the same inputs and get the same
outputs out of that type of test it's
much better so your results can be
deterministic based on some inputs and
that's a really powerful place to be
and again we're preferably on the
machine on your local machine and
subsequently through the pipe unit tests
do you have any moccasin in the room who
who really likes mocking out every
single dependency a few it's not a
shameful thing no judgement safe zone
safe salmon no judgment it's important
to actually have all these discussions
with your teams that there's no bad
answers there's just trade-offs it's
really easy to stand on a particular
soapbox in terms of which type of
testing you like but unless you can
bring that back to the value that you're
trying to deliver then it's kind of a
it's a moot it's a moot point so hear it
throughout the purposes of this we'll
assume that it's a proper full-on
mawkish style where every external
dependency of this unit is mocked out
faked out you've got fake behavior in
everything apart from the isolated unit
under test now the value per test here
value is at its lowest compared to the
other tests but it proves the least in
terms of coverage of your whole codebase
it it's a tiny slice of functionality by
definition
but that gives you power up because
obviously the feedback loop
is the shortest because it's super super
quick and the and the reliability of
that test should be it should basically
be unbreakable because this almost no
moving parts it's just the thing under
test and again we're on the machine next
you'll just hear me say that for
everything now we're moving to stuff
that's more back-end II purposefully for
the examples going to start off with API
integration tests
who's fortunate enough to work in some
in a workplace where they already do
something like contract based testing
with consumer-driven contracts only a
couple or you're in a very fortunate
space for the intents and purposes of
this we're going to go with a provider
driven contract and here what I mean by
that for in case this is assumed
knowledge what I mean is the API or the
application under test knows about its
contract and provides that contract to
interested parties a typical example
could be a public facing API where the
documentation is pretty much set in
stone because you don't know what your
consumers necessarily are really doing
with your API and as anybody who's ever
looked after a public facing API knows
that it's hell on earth to change the
contract and if you change the contract
you're going to really really make some
people angry without yeah so you want to
know that that works they in this case
provide a different contract how you
achieve this will also say that it's a
black box style test well I mean that is
what I mean by that is there's a running
process you're at your application
you're going to hit it with some HTTP a
get or a post or whatever the thing
under test is and you're going to get
back at HTTP response you might also
look at some of the side effects so
an update to a database something
getting put on a queue somewhere all
those kinds of things but you won't
touch the inner workings of the
application there is white box testing
as well but for this for this purpose
we'll go with black box and again value
per test here you've got quite a lot of
real moving things I think if we're
talking about feedback and other trade
off to think about is how many moving
real parts so say the classic argument
is do you use a real database or not now
if you want the thing to be as real to
life as possible and get the most value
out of the test yes use a real database
if you want if you're having problems
with performance that should be an
indicator for a whole other gamut of
things that you might want to think
about any non-functional requirements
but if that's a trade-off where you're
already meeting your non-functional
requirements this is okay for your
customers and you are having performance
issues with your tests then you might
think about mocking out certain aspects
of your tests but try and use real
things probably at this kind of level so
the value per test theories again really
high because it proves a lot it
exercises a lot of the stack it gives
you a lot of confidence that this is
going to be the experience that
customers get after your tests but the
trade-off can be speed although for
example I've worked in places where
there's more than 10,000 tests of this
type on a single API and they can run in
just two or three minutes as a whole
suite so it's very achievable to have
really powerful fast tests especially at
this kind of level and the other
feedback that's sorry the other
trade-off can be feedback so but again
this is an interesting exercise so
obviously when you execute this kind of
test to get feedback about the actual
execution of the underlying process and
what's going on and if it doesn't work
why this is the closest you'll get to
debugging a live issue this is the point
where you
need to know that your logging is
working the way you expect that's a
pretty valuable experience to me
you can tell what my very preferences
are again run these early left shift as
much as possible stick it on your
machine if at all possible and then in
your CI pipe at the very latest but try
and get them running and then a couple
of things that are not specifically
implementation focus so I know there's
some different opinions again on smoke
tests but I guess I'll start with the
objectives in fact on this rather than
going for the definition straightaway so
that we demonstrate value but the
objective of a smoke test for me is the
proof that the artifact that you're
deploying somewhere is running and it's
it's configured correctly things like
that it's not to test the functionality
is just its aliveness effectively you
can achieve that through monitoring and
some other things but it depends how
mature your approach is to risk in an
organization I mean let's face it we're
all doing live testing and prod all the
time because all automated testing does
is help us establish confidence that we
think it works and then we deploy it and
then hopefully it does work but yeah so
none of this replaces in fact it just
enhances the experience but you should
always have monitoring of course
continuous monitoring and all those good
things but look at just why it's
material for some of that so that's the
objective of the smoke test proving that
it works so the definition here is
something that a suite there exercises
every dependency a deployable artefact
has at least once they'll check that
your configuration is correct for any
databases any third-party services say
it has a reliance an s3 or something
just checks that it can talk to the rest
of the things that you expect it to be
able to talk to and where this is the
deviant so where this will be run only
when something is deployed to a fresh
environment you might also make these
rentable locally so that you can
add to the smoke test so you introduce a
new dependency to your service or your
application it's quite nice to get out
into the dev lifecycle so that you don't
have to wait for a deployment to know
that you smoke test still work but yeah
that's about where it stops I wouldn't
expect you to run these as late locally
I wouldn't all the time that wouldn't
make a lot of sense and when it comes to
implementation I try to keep these above
implementation detail but when it comes
to implementation I'd expect it for a
front-end based application so you go
all the way to the micro front-end thing
then you'd expect some kind of maybe
some UI tests very I'm hesitant to say
UI tests because it gives you a certain
thing a certain feeling that it's going
to be a whole journey and all that kind
of thing but know what I'm really
interested in is you hitting every
dependency once so if you've outsourced
the idea of identity 200 auth some earth
provider or something like that you
might have a flow that uses that
third-party service once just the proof
that it's configured correctly you've
not somehow jabbed in the wrong public
key for something in some system whether
that's a hkm store or something like
that okay then the lovely idea of
acceptance we all accept that this story
is is as we say it is you know has
anybody ever had a separate acceptance
test suite yeah I'd call that out as an
anti-pattern really it's a bit weird
just because for me the idea of
accepting it acceptance isn't just tests
it's the whole team achieving acceptance
of that story for a start and in testing
terms the the nicest analogy I've seen
is the Swiss cheese analogy there was a
blog seven days ago published by
somebody called Carney who works for
thought works but they talked about the
Swiss cheese model and the analogy here
is every layer of tests that you have is
effectively a
slice of Swiss cheese with all the holes
in it and as you layer these slices of
cheese together ultimately you're going
to get to a point where hopefully
there's not many holes of light going
all the way through the block of cheese
and then you know that you've covered
pretty much most of the scenarios that
is expected in terms of behavior of your
software and that helps you achieve
acceptance I thought that was a really
nice analogy so I stole it but I'm
giving credit so it's okay yeah like any
good university student not that I even
have a degree anyway so achieved across
layers it's a next up next up we will
talk about strategy so for our first
example we will have a micro front-end
spar bleeding edge like tiny application
let's say it deals with just I don't
know search on your website it's not
really important what this is and you
would expect to see is this way yeah you
don't expect to see just these tests may
be for this few arguments of our
definitions earlier rather than saying
just these tests we'll talk a little bit
now about some of the trade-offs earlier
and the kind of blend of tests that you
might expect to see so that we can have
more of a discourse on why you would
choose certain amounts of tests where
and why so with the UI tests for example
going by our earlier definition we know
that these deliver a lot of value but
they come with quite a lot of cost so by
that definition you want some but not
too many so for the purposes of this
really tiny application what you can
probably say is that you can still keep
that fast and cover maybe all the happy
path journeys that might be sufficient
you might still get the execution time
out of it that you need and deliver the
value exactly what your execution
targets are with your team let's say in
this case five minutes is the maximum
we'll accept for a suite run
just that of argument sake so your goal
is to make sure that this suite can run
in under that time and obviously try and
parallel ice the suite runs so you're
not waiting forever for everything
component tests these were quite nice
they proved quite a lot but they did do
it in isolation and they're much more
reliable so maybe in this case the bulk
of our testing will probably be in the
component tests specific comes with the
least negative trade-offs we get a lot
of surety a lot of confidence and less
of the downsides and then unit testing
interesting what would you expect a unit
test in this scenario maybe it's some
core logic that's shared across multiple
components maybe something like that
there is an argument to say just use the
concrete the concrete implementation in
the component tests and then you almost
have a consumer-driven contract for the
Intel well the internal application
logic but you also might want to isolate
that functionality and provide a
contract to the potential consumers and
you prove reliably that that works the
way you expect
and then lastly smoke test just to again
go over it once make sure it's alive
make sure it's okay in this particular
setup probably a couple of UI tests just
to check the dependencies don't check
the logic you've already proved that
you've accepted this story by this point
it it's ok we can move on to the land
where we're just checking that in this
environment we've not done goofed who is
release something and realize that you
don't have a the right a sell
certificate yeah for a new API nobody
can get to it excellent anyway the
second example would be more of a
back-end thing
so for the arguments for the purpose of
this argument we'll say it's a
public-facing HTTP API that happens to
be running as a micro service I won't
for public facing because you don't know
who the consumers are necessarily or how
they're consuming your API which is
always a bag bag of fun now
here somewhat controversially maybe I
expect possibly almost all the testing
to occur in the integration layer
because you can get those tests running
really quickly really reliably and they
provide a lot of value they also help
you know that you can diagnose issues if
they're if well if there are any issues
when there are issues in your production
environments you get a lot of value out
of those tests and a yeah I'm pretty
convinced that in almost all cases
barring maybe some way you've got some
really expensive dependencies you can
get those tests running really quickly
or you should be able to because that is
the contract you have with the public at
the end of the day and if you can't get
your endpoints running a reasonable base
then that's the experience your
customers have of using your API so
that's not a good thing
then unit tests come in and they do have
value so some examples of some things
which break the rule of integration
testing there it would be if you want to
prove say if a database node goes
offline what the hell the behavior is if
you want to set up an environment and
knock out nodes and things as part of
your test suite like that's that's a
really cool thing you'll be there awhile
and getting those tests to a point where
they're really reliable is it's not it's
not a good trade-off so writing that
into some unit tests will provide a lot
of value those unit tests here we're
from our definition earlier so you might
want to write them at the various levels
where you expect some kind of different
behavior maybe you're returning 503 s
now instead of sort of something else
and then smoke tests again just to prove
the aliveness
that brings me onto coupling so coupling
when you introduce tests you introduce
coupling you say I have this contract
and I'm proving that it works the way I
expect that is a really high piece of
cohesion and coupling right there so
much like when you're thinking about
your microsociology I want somewhere so
they're the same should be true for
tests because you ideally want these
contracts to be stable because that
means that you don't have to rewrite the
tests all the time it means that you're
getting the biggest bang for your buck
the particularly the HTTP API that we're
talking about is a wonderful example
because you have these really stable
contracts with public parties or with
other teams and you don't want to change
them willy-nilly but you'll just upset a
lot of people and that that is a ideal
point for coupling because you have that
stability in the UI land you're kind of
screwed to put it politely I don't think
I've ever seen the UI that's remained
stable forever so unlucky but yeah just
look for points where you know that
there's good stability that can be
another discussion that you can have
because that will lead you down a path
where you don't want to kill yourself
every time you have to make a change to
the piece of software that's covered
with these all these lovely tests so say
somebody I used to work with used to
really like test-driven development and
ask I do too but he proposed that maybe
after top-down chess driving his feature
he was just going to delete all the unit
tests that were already covered to
further up that was his compromise this
is something to just talk about there is
always trade-offs always trade-offs so
if you can bring it back to the value
that you're trying to deliver that
feedback the documentation the
confidence every single time that's when
you're going to get the right results
and just making it a safe place where
anybody can talk about testing I know
it's a heated thing but there's no
there's no one correct answer because it
was in the title and because I wrote the
talk after I wrote the title and thought
okay I didn't also want to put a picture
but if you imagine here we're deleting
out a chunk of the unit tests you kind
of cut off the bottom of the pyramid and
turn it into a lovely diamond shape but
I hated myself too much to put it on
here I couldn't I just couldn't do it
I couldn't do it so I'm sorry but
imagine the diamond is staring at you
okay and just going to reiterate it one
small parenthesis this is a sea of gray
unfortunately that's life there is no
correct one approach one hammer to hit
every nail with you have to build a
toolset and part of that toolset is your
team and having those healthy
conversations with the team about what
all the words mean what the value is
you're trying to represent it kind of
comes into the Google sre book as well
which is lovely about establishing some
common measures if you all have a preset
set of measures that you know you're
punching to hit or that you can talk
about that's that's some common language
established right there
you can talk ubiquitously about these
kinds of things and it helps diffuse it
helps turn it into a healthy discussion
about as all achieving the best job
rather than somebody really likes this
type of testing so to recap we didn't
cover a bunch of stuff that's semi
deliberate because I want to keep you
here all day but accessibility
performance security and for a
continuous monitoring everything there
is a lot to testing of various different
types please do it all we're at all
possible do it in the features keep it
as close and tightly coupled and left
shifted sorry as left shifted as
possible do it on the machine do it
earliest stages of your pipeline
wherever you can
there are some exceptions to the rule
but wherever you can left shift and in
summary we started with the value we
talked about the three tenants of what I
think produce value in tests the one
kind of missing one was maintainability
it's kind of inferred but in case you
want to make sure that your tests are
also maintainable at the end of the day
we established a common dialogue about
some of the words we went through a
couple of examples of trade-offs and
strategies and we just basically talked
about the whole thing being a sea of
gray and I'm not any help to you all
right
for resources there are some really good
blogs with a lot of history James Shaw
Geico Jess for the continuous monitoring
corny I mentioned with the lovely Swiss
cheese example and your peers the people
sat next to you right now they'll have
opinions I came to this talk I'm sure
you can have really interesting
discussion I mean I'm downstairs blotto
after this and plugging it again pop
Kampf it is a lot of fun it's not an NDC
run event but by people who are well
working with no not working with
speaking out the conference it's fair to
say and it's a lot of fun five minute
ignite talks people make well
pulls themselves really he'll try to and
just have fun doing it no no cameras no
videos it's it's a closed doors kind of
event so that people can talk just let
their hair down and say what say just
funny stuff without their of their
company sacking them and then I'm a
co-founder and co-organizer of another
Dedede conference for those and
ingratiated it's the developer developer
developers umbrella of conferences
they're all free or near free nominal
fee ours is completely free its run in
the Midlands October 3rd oh there it is
ok it's public submission anyone here
could speak and it's anon
spoked so anybody attending the
conference can vote on the topics they
want to see and your submission is in
your face your name are not shown is
only the titles and the abstracts so
you'll have a pretty damn good chance of
getting it and we offer a lot of support
for first-time speakers and video
recordings and things so you can more
easily get to events like this okay
lastly thank you very much
hopefully forgive the subliminal
messaging right there but don't have any
questions as well from anybody nope
okay then I'm on floor two afterwards
come find me thank you very much